I wanted to note that I'm going to talk
about several different studies and I
have a lot of
these and so by no means is all this my
own work in addition there's a lot of
people have done the dirty work on our
studies we do a lot of field ecology in
our lab as well so I'm gonna be talking
about the ecology of global change and
infectious diseases and I want to point
out a couple things firstly I'm not
gonna be talking solely about climate
and I'm not gonna be talking solely
about human infectious diseases although
I will touch on both of those things
when I talk about global change the four
things that I have worked on and my
career have been general stressors like
pollution I'll talk about that I'll talk
about climate change next then I'll talk
about biodiversity loss and I'll finish
with introduce species and how all those
things interact with infectious disease
processes
so first section it's real brief it's
about stress and parasites and it's
really going to have as its core a
theoretical component and I promise this
is about as bad as the graphs get and
I'll actually take a little bit of time
to set this up so if we start with a
simple si model and we from that model
we calculate something called R naught
which should be familiar to many of you
we can plot R naught greater than 1 or
less than 1 in in a parameter space here
and are not less than 1 we get no
disease are not greater than 1 we get
disease and the axes of this graph are
how susceptible the host population is
the rate of parasite mortality on the
vertical axis and then the line that
separates the space is the slope of this
line is related to the host carrying
capacity so let me explain how this
works if we have high susceptibility we
tend to have more opportunities for
disease we have high parasite at
mortality fewer opportunities for
disease as the slope of the carrying
capacity increases then this line would
go up this way and we get more
opportunities for disease because of
mass action transmission more dense host
populations more opportunities for Z so
this is just one way to graphically
represent the Arnott equation for an SI
model and then we can ask questions
about stress because stress might
interact with all three of these factors
we might have stress increasing host
susceptibility we might also suspect
that stress could increase parasite
mortality either throwing
using host mortality or parasite
mortality directly and then stress in
the system might also affect the host
carrying capacity often we assume it
might decrease the host carrying
capacity so here's an example of how
that could work let's start with a
situation where the population is not
subject to an infectious disease and we
can stress the system we can decrease
the carrying capacity increase parasite
mortality increase susceptibility now
we've shifted we've added stress to that
system we've moved from not having the
disease to having the disease that's one
way it can work in this same model we
can start with a population now this one
is subject to disease we can stress the
system but we'll stress it qualitatively
in a similar fashion but quantitatively
the relative stress will be different
and now we can move that system from
supporting disease to not supporting the
disease all this is showing you is that
with a very simple model we can make an
argument for how stress can either
increase or decrease the risk of
infectious disease transmission because
of its effect on these three elements
that are important we can go to the
literature and a while back I did sort
of a literature summary of various
stressors mostly in aquatic systems and
how they related to observations on
mostly parasitic diseases and here's
what that tabulation shows it's a
complicated table but it's actually
fairly straightforward that rows
represent different parasite groups the
columns represent different stressors
and A+ indicates that stress increases
infectious disease and then minus sign
represents that stress decreases
infectious disease we filled this table
and more recent studies but we get the
same thing basically there are areas of
this table where there are positive
associations in areas where there tend
to be negative associations I thought
I'd point out one important thing and
that is that the stressor where we tend
to get consistently positive
associations with infectious diseases is
eutrophication and the primary reason
that we get this is because this tends
to increase post carrying capacity host
densities and that makes it easier for
diseases to transmit
context so that I think this brief
introduction to pollution and stress
sort of sets up the context for the
other three sections of my talk which is
that we can expect complex outcomes of
environmental change and infectious
disease it's not simply going to be one
thing or the other and in particular
although most people might expect that
stress would increase infectious disease
at the host individual level and we
start asking questions at the host
population level we can get different
sorts of outcomes let's talk about
climate change parasites in in general
it's this isn't going to be about
debating whether climate change occurs
or not it's going to be about how
temperature can affect with interact
with vector transmitted diseases and the
for me the most important of those is
malaria and this came home to me I was
in Senegal working on it's just a so
myiasis project and I was talking to one
of my hosts there and I asked him if he
was taking Malarone
which is the the prophylactics that you
take when you go to Africa to keep from
getting malaria and of course he laughed
at me because he said is you know I've
had malaria many times and everybody I
know has had malaria and they does we
don't take prophylaxis here and it
really underscored that for a spoiled
North American like me our views of
tropical diseases are really from afar
and it's it's sort of unusual that we
get the opportunity to sort of
experience them firsthand you got to go
to Africa sort of to do that and I've
been I've been teaching parasitology
earlier in my career and came across
this this paper that really helped me
communicate to my students that malaria
was important for them so this is the
current more or less a model of the
current distribution of malaria and also
the what the model represents as areas
that may be currently suitable for
transmission and what this paper did was
simply say let's take what we think we
know about the relationship between
temperature and large
mission and project this to Global
Change estimates and where are we gonna
see malaria in the future and so I could
show these patterns to my students and
convince them that malaria was coming to
them and that was why they should really
care to learn more about it much later
in my career it became I don't know
climate change
biology and infectious disease became
more faddish in our discipline and so
there are many many papers coming up
with the conclusion that climate change
was going to increase infectious
diseases of many types and so I started
to worry about the details of the models
that went into these sorts of
predictions and so here's an example of
what we call a process base malaria
model and we know that there's a lot of
vital rates of both the mosquito and the
Plasmodium parasite that are sensitive
to temperature and that then we can
build models that can be parameterized
as functions of temperature and generate
how what the expect expectation is for
how malaria might respond at temperature
here's an example of how these rates are
used so the probably the most
sophisticated malaria model at the time
was based on parameterizing models from
relationships empirical relationships
done experimentally where you look at
your development rate of the mosquito
versus temperature and from these sorts
of relationships if you plug all this
sort of thing into that sort of model
you can fit and are not function of
temperature or not again being the
probability of an epidemic occurring and
a fully susceptible population and the
key thing for this are not curve is that
the peak sort of the sweet spot for a
falciparum malaria transmission it's
expected to be about 31 degrees C once
you have that that sweet spot now you
can do things like map the current
distribution of malaria and map where
you would expect malaria to be in the
future based on maps of temperature and
future temperature well the thing that
worried me about these models is the
data that these linear fits are taken
from are oftentimes
not linear when when experimenters use
relatively high temperatures they find
oftentimes these unimodel hump shape
relationships so I was working with a
group of really bright graduate students
and postdocs at an NCS
working group on climate change and
disease and what we decided to do was to
go back to the original data and see
what would happen if we fit a malaria
model to these nonlinear relationships
that the data imply are important and
our approach was to go through the
literature fit those physiological
responses with the data and basically
use what we know is generally the case
that ectotherm physiology has these
nonlinear relationships with temperature
we then calculated our not using these
models as a function of temperature and
then we did what other people hadn't
done which is to validate the model
predictions with field data from Africa
so I'm specifically looking at
falciparum malaria in Africa here so you
would think that we would know a lot
about how mosquitoes and Plasmodium
respond to temperature it turns out we
do know a fair bit about it but most of
those data are fairly old and not
particularly complete but we were able
to get what we thought were at least
reasonable estimates of these curves for
the key the seven key vital rates that
we needed to do the model when we do our
model which is essentially the same
structural model as people have used in
the past we also get a you know model
hump shaped curve but if you look you
can see the sweet spot for a mouse about
super malaria transmission is very
different from what people have seen in
the past which is the red curve so a
shift in six degrees C so of course what
we like to know is which one of these
things is true and we can go to actual
transmission records for malaria in
Africa and compare it to field data for
temperature and we see that we think
we've got a much better fit for that 25
degrees C peak than for the 31 degrees C
peak
I thought was fascinating that you know
for for many years we believed in this
curve without actually seeing that it
didn't really fit the data very well so
then the question is what do you do with
these data and we decided to ask whether
our model gave you different looking
graphs I'll just show you some pictures
that we're working on currently so we
know what the temperature looks like
average temperature looks like every
month in Africa at sort of the kilometer
scale resolution and here's an example
from March about where we think
conditions are too hot for malaria where
they're too cold and where they're just
about right okay we can look across the
months and we can see that it really
changes from month a month the
conditions from malaria and we know that
in many cases malaria transmission is
quite seasonal seasonal some places have
12 months of the years other places is
just a few months of the year
we can plot those things over the time
so you can see the seasonality of
malaria there in that central panel this
is a different scale and just simply
shows if you were to sum across all
months and we were to go from light
being very little malaria transmission
to the very darker purple colors being a
lot of malaria transmission what we
currently expect malaria transmission to
be like across Africa and again this
this is the pattern that fits the
existing data fairly well we can take
this and we can ask what happens with
climate change projections of
temperature change in Africa and we see
some noticeable changes in 2080 from the
current and primarily that being the
areas that are right now really good for
malaria transmission might not be so
good for malaria transmission in the
future but we have new areas that are
going to be pretty good for malaria
transmission in the future and when I
say good for malaria transmission I
simply mean the temperature conditions
suitable for malaria whether malaria
actually transmits or not in these areas
is really a function of many other
things and
talk about that a minute but if we were
to ask then what about is is malaria
gonna increase with climate change or
not here's one way sort of to think
about that here's time on the x-axis
here and the darkness of the bar
represents different types of malaria
transmission so overall slight increase
in amount of area of Africa where
malaria transmission might occur at some
time during the year but if you just
interested in severe malaria
transmission for instance that's
declining by about half or more the
previous model told a very different
story in two ways firstly what it
assumed was that malaria was gonna
increase in area of any any kind of
malaria transmission would be increasing
particularly and most dominantly the
severe malaria transmission so that was
really I think the key difference
between past models and ours but another
one that's sort of interesting I thought
was that past models really
underestimated how good things were for
malaria now right now things are
actually pretty good for malaria better
than we would have assumed if we had
gone with that 31 degree peak so that's
the the temperature interaction with
malaria but I want to underscore that
maybe this doesn't mean that much for
malaria transmission because we know
there's plenty of places right now where
malaria can be transmitted I mean that
the conditions are fine for malaria
transmission but we don't see malaria
transmission occurring and one of the
key correlates for that has to do with
economics so if people are you know
wealthy then they spend more time
indoors and they have screens on their
windows and they're separated more from
the vector they also have access to
public health etc and so one of the key
drivers of malaria that may be even more
important than temperature is per capita
GDP and there's an another store study
that looked at if you consider if you if
you can believe the economists about
increases in GDP throughout the world in
the future and you lay that on top of
expectations for climate change you get
a different story about what we're going
to expect to see
in terms of conditions for malaria and
basically red is expansion
and blue is contraction you see there's
really no blue on this globe at all so
the expectation is basically that
although conditions are getting better
in some parts of Africa in the future
potentially in terms of temperature for
malaria transmission there's going to be
an overriding effect of changes in
economics that's going to pretty much
mask those climate change effects I'll
just add one caveat this doesn't mean
that climate change might not have
another effect on malaria transmission
through its effect on economics in other
words maybe the biggest effect that
climate change might have on malaria
will be through disrupting economies and
putting more people into poverty in
which case these projections of
increasing GDP might not hold and we
could see a worse situation for a
malaria transmission all right
biodiversity loss and parasites I took
out the Lyme disease part of this talk I
figure you guys knew about that it gave
me more time to talk about other stuff
I'm happy to talk about it during
questions if you want ok biodiversity
loss what are we talking about well the
conservation biologists tell us that
they expect 15 to 30 percent loss in
biodiversity with climate change the
details here aren't that important just
that we have that number and we can ask
at least I'm interested in knowing what
does this mean for parasite biodiversity
in the world no one cares about parasite
diversity really perhaps except me but
we've been using a sort of a food web
approach here's an example the types of
food webs that we put in we've have been
building here the red balls or free
living species and the yellow balls or
parasite species this is for an estuary
about 20 minutes south at UCSB and we
can do once we have these food webs
built we can do very simple experiments
in the computer where we drive
biodiversity down we can cause a species
to go extinct like let's say that's a
fish and if that fish has a host
specific parasite then that host
specific parasite will probably go
extinct from the system too we can do
these sorts
of sequences sequential extinctions
thousands and thousands of times and
sort of plot what the relationship is
expected to be between free living
richness and parasite richness and this
shouldn't really come too much of a
surprise to people but basically as we
reduce free living richness we should
expect to see it a Cline in Paris
originals now we go to the field and see
if we can get some empirical estimates
of this and so we've been studying one
aspect of the estuary community that
people care about and those are the bird
community and we have an interesting
opportunity in this system due to a
group of parasites called the trematode
z-- who have a complex life cycle so the
trematode z-- are all in birds and
there's about 18 different species 12 of
which are common and they have a complex
life cycle and the first intermediate
hostnet life cycle is a single species
of snail it's relatively long live snail
it's 5 10 20 years and the mudflats and
so basically these snails for us they
act like mobile long live data recorders
if a bird comes by and defecates and
leaves trematode eggs on the mud there's
a chance that that snail would become
infected we can pick that up snail up
dissect it look inside and if we see
that it is infected that tells us at
some point in time a bird came by
because there's a several different
species of treatment toads they have
different life cycles because they use
different second intermediate hosts and
then birds have different diets so that
means they get exposed to different
species of trematode then our prediction
would be areas that have a high
diversity of birds should have a high
diversity leave a high diversity of
trematode x' and the snails areas that
have a high abundance of birds should
leave many snails infected so here's one
way that we go about assessing
biodiversity in the field we can go out
to a site like this and all these little
dots on the mudflat these are the snails
they're super common they're easy to
pick up a low tide we know how to
identify the parasites visually with a
dissecting scope so getting the
information on the trematode x' is not
very difficult it's a bit harder to get
information on this birds because
whenever you come out to our plots this
is what you see there's just
either you scare the birds away or maybe
birds aren't that abundant at this
particular spatial scale and so we've
been using time lapse videography we set
up these cameras that take five seconds
of video every minute 12 hours a day for
14 days it gives us 2000 clips you can
do this with camera traps that are
motion activated to this this happened
to work better for our particular study
and I thought I'd give you an example of
what some of those videos look like this
is a low res version but on the on the
real video we can tell what each species
looks like and identify it we can tell
if they're feeding or if they're just
cruising through at high tide we can
still see the birds even though it's
difficult to go out there on our own at
high tide and then the best thing about
it of course we don't disturb the birds
and we can get a good idea about who's
actually out there and even though
there's 2,000 clips it turns out that
undergraduates are sort of pre adapted
to looking at clips and can tell us
which ones deserve better inspection so
went now if we we take the diversity
data from the birds and the diversity
data from the parasites and we plot them
together we get a what we might expect
which is that areas with lots of bird
species have lots of parasite species in
those snails to different habitat types
where we've conducted these studies I
could also show you bird abundance
versus parasite abundance and
essentially just the same figure so that
looks like at least some empirical
support for this positive relationship
between free living richness and
parasite richness and we can ask then
what happens with a expected reduction
of 15 to 37 percent in biodiversity we
might expect then a subsequent a bunch
of secondary parasite extinctions but I
think it's also important to remember
that parasites they're not only simply
dependent on their hosts but they have
their own thermal physiology their own
niches they have free living stages that
interact with the environment etc
and so it's quite feasible that
parasites could suffer primary
extinctions in addition to secondary
extinct
and if this was the case then we might
expect actually parasite richness to
decline faster than free living richness
in the future with climate change I
bring this up primarily because this is
exactly the opposite of what most people
would expect would happen to parasites
with climate change most of literature
you'll read will say that we're gonna
suffer a lot more infectious diseases as
a result and that may be the case in
some instances some of which I'll get to
in a minute as a marine biologist I'm
often concerned with this scenario this
isn't the future this is actually the
present and we've at we've seen this
sort of historical change over the last
hundred fifty years in the ocean where
systems have gotten a lot more
simplified and we've been interested in
what this means for parasites in the
ocean one of the systems that were most
concerned about are coral reefs because
this has been one of the places where
we've seen so much degradation and loss
of biodiversity so our goal was to
compare parasites in coral reefs that
are fished in coral reefs that are not
fished and it turns out that this is
where we do our work in the Pacific it's
easy to find areas that are fished the
hard part is spawning areas that are not
fished for comparison so we got to work
in the line islands and our fish
location has been Carissa Moss there's a
coral atoll it's has a high population
density of very very poor people and
they essentially fish for sustenance and
they have major impacts on the fish reef
community and then by comparison
we go to Palmira atoll which was never
found by humans I mean it's been found
by humans but only recently so there
hasn't been major damage to it and it's
not fished it's a protected area it has
been for some time
here's what Palmira atoll looks like
when you fly into it we have a research
station on the atoll and when we show up
after the flight down from Honolulu you
want to jump in the water and go
snorkeling this is what you see little
fish and
one thing you'll notice about those fish
is they're sort of nervous looking
because this is what they're looking at
on all day long are these massive
predators that are still present at
Palmira so we looked at a damsel fish
alright you're saying a chromis a
surgeon a snapper a damsel up on top and
then down here as a fifth species hawk
fish these were fish that we figured we
could sample at both locations and
reasonable numbers and on Palmyra we
went to sample these things by netting
them but the fish were so nervous that
we really couldn't get close enough to
net them and we instead opted to shoot
them with little Spears made out of
rubber bands and coat hangers which
doesn't look very macho but it actually
is more difficult than it looks like the
problem with doing this fieldwork is
this is another view of our study sites
very rich with these gray reef sharks
also black tips and white tips and this
is this is video I took during a 20
minute dive so this is you know not
necessarily an exaggeration and so the
the sharks aren't too concerned when
you're shooting a little fish but when
you go to shoot those big snappers they
can get really excited and we set off
some shark feeding frenzies that got a
little out of control so instead of
shooting the larger snappers and stuff
we went and moved a hook and line and
Suzanne tell me if you recognize who
that is it's one of her colleagues from
grad school anyways this is you don't
always get the fish to the surface in
palmira so that's all just to impress
upon you that there are differences
between palmira where you can see 20 30
100 sharks on a dye versus Christmas
where you go for two weeks and you might
see two in dissecting those reef fishes
we found lots of new parasites that
nobody had ever seen before many of them
hadn't been described but we were able
to sort of at least describe them to
group and list them as punitive species
and here's just a simple tabulation in
comparison of the two sites Palmyra for
the five species of fish we
consistently higher parasite richness
per fish across-the-board compared to
that heavily fish site in Christmas and
we think this is a result really of
removing a lot of those top predators
from the system and simplifying the food
webs that those parasites depend on
here's an example of one of those
species this is a tapeworm that uses
sharks as a final host and then goes
into that little Hawk fish for an
intermediate host and you can see that
in Palmyra where we have tons of sharks
not surprisingly there's lots of larval
shark tapeworms in those hawk fish all
right so we can go back to the food web
and I wanted to just show you another
scenario of sort of an alternative way
that things can work so let's say we
cause a free-living species to go
extinct but that free living species is
a predator on some other species so we
might see some indirect increases in the
prey of species that are removed and if
those prey have parasites than those
parasites might increase in abundance so
there are possible ways that reducing
biodiversity in a certain way might
result in increases in infectious
disease and here's an example from kelp
forests in Santa Barbara so we have
here's a very simplified view of the
kelp forest food web we have lobsters
that eat sea urchins keep sea urchins at
relatively low abundance and that
releases kelp from being grazed down by
sea urchins but throughout most of
Southern California the food chain looks
like this because we fish almost every
legal sized Lobster from the system
in many cases that leads to large
abundances of sea urchins and reduced
kelp and one of the consequences of that
is there's interactions between fishing
and bacterial epidemics and sea urchins
what we see is that this graph shows the
abundance of sea urchins in different
sites and the probability that we see an
epidemic at those sites and you can see
that basically below a very low density
of
we don't see epidemics and that
increases the more sea urchins that we
have and that's really basic
epidemiology about you know what we
would expect for hosts in close contact
have more efficient transmission of
directly transmitted diseases so here's
another way to look at it we can compare
the abundance of these organisms in
marine reserves compared to fished areas
marine reserves have lots of lobsters
compared to fished areas few errands
lots of kelp and epidemics of bacteria
really rare in reserves and really
common in fished areas so here's an
example of how fishing can increase
infectious disease and it has
consequences for the system because if
you have a really big epidemic this is
the prevalence of the disease during an
epidemic on the x-axis the population
growth rate of sea urchins the following
year tends to be very negative this is
just a way to show that these epidemics
can have high mortality and as a
response to an epidemic if we look at
what happens to the kelp in the system
we tend to see an increase in kelp
following massive epidemics so another
way to look at this is we take lobsters
out of the system when we fish them but
disease kind of fills in that vacuum
that's left by the missing lobsters all
right we want to know how general this
was so we went to the Galapagos where we
have a very similar type of food web
different players but necess
interestingly enough of different
parasites more interesting parasites
maybe ones that you haven't heard of
these are specialized gastropods called
new limits and they're parasitic on
echinoderms two different species one
that lives in the spine one that sucks
the gonads out through the test and the
expectation then is that these parasites
would follow the same sort of patterns
that we saw in Santa Barbara an increase
in response in fishing but one of the
differences in this food web are these
small crabs that shelter underneath the
spines of pencil urchins and the crabs
eat snails so this small change in the
complexity or increased
the complexity of the system makes the
food web look a little bit different and
now it becomes a little bit more
difficult to predict exactly what the
net effect of phishing is but again by
comparing marine reserves and fished
areas we can get some expectations of
the patterns and what we see is that
overall there tends to be a negative
effect of fishing on parasites in this
system very similar food web but that
one change completely reverses the
dynamics okay here's another case which
actually has some public health
relevance one of the more important
tropical diseases may have heard about
is called schistosomiasis it's a snail
vector disease in a lot of tropical
areas and we've been working on this
parasite in Senegal along the senegal
river basin and basically prior to the
late 80s
just as myiasis was really rare in the
Senegal River and then to improve
agriculture they put in a dam that
prevented the tide from going upstream
from the oceans called the d ama dam and
basically that was very successful in
allowing for the irrigation of sugarcane
fields along the river made some of
those landowner owners very rich and it
led to the most massive outbreak in
schistosomiasis that's ever been
recorded which is still ongoing and we
were interested to know whether the
putting this dam and had changed aspects
of the food web in ways that might have
favoured schistosomiasis
there's many changes of course that
occur with dams but one of the ones that
we were particularly interested in was
the fact that prior to the dam the
villagers used to fish these giant River
prawns which are now gone from the
system we can't find them there anymore
and one of the thoughts is that these
giant River prawns particularly when
they're small love to eat snails they're
a great source of both calcium for the
snail and for protein
and so we've been doing laboratory
experiments for instance where you take
the two main snail vectors it's just a
samaya system in tanks we let them start
growing in a population and then we can
compare without prawns where the snail
populations really increase or with
prawns where they hardly do anything
same for this snail vector here and what
we're particularly interested in is how
predation varies according to the size
of the prawn and here's why
in Senegal what the villagers really
need is they need a break from
schistosomiasis and they need a way to
make money and prawns are actually a
very lucrative fishery so in theory we
could use either aquaculture or
restoration to bring prawns back into
that system give the villagers something
to fish and perhaps also get snail
control as a result and it turns out
that the way that the prawn population
works is the very large prawns are
cannibalistic and they eat the small
prawns and the small prawns are the best
snail predators so the best way to get
snail control from a prawn population is
actually to fish the large prawns which
are the most valuable economically so
we're hoping that we can start to move
towards implementation at the moment
what we have is a field experiment where
we've gone to these four villages and we
start out by treating everybody in the
village for schistosomiasis we've given
prize equal there they're all cured and
this is a normal sort of treatment that
the health agencies do there the problem
being that within six weeks or so
everybody becomes reinfected because
they use the water as part of their
daily lives and their snails in these
areas where people do the laundry and
swim etcetera so we've set up big
enclosures and in at some of these
villages we have then gone and
introduced river prawns that we get from
Cameroon it's the same species and we
put them in and and then the idea is to
look and see how come back later and
look at the villagers and see how many
have become reinfected in these four
villages and so far
are the villages where we've introduced
bronze into those sites have much slower
rates of reinfection I just got news
yesterday that our suggestion to put a
fish ladder on the D AMA Dam to allow
prawns to reestablish their migration
with the estuary has been met with a lot
of positive feedback from the dam
Authority and the reason that's
important is that this prawn uses the
estuary to breed and that's what
essentially when you put a dam that
prevents the prawn from persisting but
with a fish ladder perhaps we can get a
natural population back in okay so I've
just given you examples about how
biodiversity loss can potentially
decrease infectious disease other
examples where biodiversity loss like
damming in this case might increase
infectious disease if you're familiar
with the literature there's a hypothesis
that's very popular amongst conservation
biologists called the dilution effect
and the idea is that there can be this
win-win relationship between
conservation and human health where if
we protect biodiversity that that should
reduce disease risk and there's some
interesting there's some logical aspects
of this hypothesis and our view was that
it had perhaps been embraced a little
bit too quickly because of its win-win
outcome and so we did sort of a thought
exercise of hypothesis generation and
what we wanted to do is to ask
systematically for important parasitic
diseases of humans where would we expect
biodiversity to increase infectious
disease or biodiversity to decrease
infectious disease so the first step in
this was to come up with a list of
parasites that we could work with and so
we the list that we work with excludes
viruses and bacteria but it includes
protozoans and major helmets and
basically to be on the list you had to
cause some sort of significant tap
ecology and people and at least
somewhere in the world be relatively
prevalent and so here's the list you
don't have to read any of it but that's
69 different parasitic diseases that we
went through one by one and then applied
about eight different criteria to ask
should we expect a positive or negative
relationship with biodiversity this
paper will be coming out in ecology
sometime soon and this is just the
summary and the tabulation of our
hypothesized response so perhaps this
was a surprising thing is that we would
expect a very large fraction to not be
related to biodiversity all these are
primarily going to be the directly
transmitted diseases that don't really
interact with other species in the
environment we do certainly see examples
of cases where we would hypothesize that
we will see more disease with
biodiversity loss but about three times
as many cases where we hypothesize that
we should see less disease with
biodiversity loss of course these are
hypotheses what we'd like to do or what
we'd like to see is that this would do
two things one is to get people to go
out and test these specific agents and
also to at least have a broader view of
the potential negative or positive
effects that infectious that
biodiversity can have on infectious
diseases alright this is the last
section in the talk it's pretty short
section this is a colleague of mine Mark
torchin and mark is holding a very large
crab called the European green crab and
that's this one this is a large crab
from Europe in comparison to the crab
from San Francisco Bay where this crab
is invasive the European crabs are all
tiny and so we've been interested in
trying to figure out why invasive
species do so well and one potential
reason for that is that when they invade
they leave many of their parasites
behind so the green crab was a model
system for us because it had been
introduced one two three four or five
different places around the world and we
could go to Europe and look at the
parasites in the native range and
compare it to replicate places where the
crab had been introduced and the native
range the crab
definitely has a lot of parasites as
indicated by the size of this pie and
several different species of parasites
as well when we go around the world and
and collect equivalent samples what we
find is that in many places there are no
parasites in South Africa also no
parasites and in other places a few
parasites the place where we have the
most parasites is on the east coast here
where green crabs have been here for
more than 150 years and not only are
they very close geographically but
they've had time potentially to
accumulate parasites so that's one
species that when introduced species
that seems to have fewer parasites were
its invasive and also performs very well
where it's invasive and we see good
evidence that at least some of these
parasites may be responsible for its or
the loss of some of these parasites are
responsible for some of its increased
performance we can also look at a review
of 26 animal taxa where we have good
data to compare parasite species between
the native range and the introduced
range and so on average for our 26
animal taxa there's about 16 parasite
species none where the animal is native
okay so that's sort of the average and
where these animals have been introduced
we say they only bring with them about
two of those species so this is an
example of introduced species escaping
parasites because perhaps they come over
as larvae or in small sample sizes and
you just don't sample the full
complement of parasites in that
introduced range but introduced species
pick up parasites in the new range they
acquire on average about four parasite
species it still doesn't make up for all
the parasites that they've left behind
in their native range and so we may have
some evidence for well it's my lab
meeting today that's nice
I'd much rather be here
so we see at least some general support
for the fact that this enemy release may
be a general phenomenon there's two
points I really wanted to make about
this the first is that if invasive
species are showing up without their
full complement of parasites that may
help them do better but the other thing
which I think is more important
potentially is that if every invader
brings with it two parasite species then
species invasions are three times bigger
than we think they are and some of these
parasite species that they bring we know
can be problematic for native species
and cause additional problems so what
does this mean just this is the last
study I'll talk about how to do with a
food web of an Arctic lake that we've
been putting together in Norway and this
is an example of what that food web
looked like we think before about 1940
the free living species are indicated by
these boxes here that run across in the
main part of the web and free living
predator prey links are in black
parasites are up here on the right hand
column and their interactions the host
parasite interactions are in red okay
and so it's a complex system parasites
add a lot to this complexity but the
Norwegians like in a lot of places added
two species of fish to their web they
added arctic char and stickleback and
this is what the food web looks like now
it looks a lot more complicated than it
did before
and it's not just because so they added
these two species to the web but we got
five more parasites that complete their
life cycle in the lake as a result in an
addition for bird species that could
feed in that lake as a result of these
introductions the main reason I wanted
to to put this slide in is that it sort
of addresses two points the first is
that yes introduced species can bring
parasites into a system but it also
emphasizes the point that increases in
biodiversity facilitate opportunities
for parasites to complete their life
cycles in systems
so let me conclude with the following
points the first is that stress can
increase or decrease parasites this was
really important to consider when you're
thinking about effects at the population
level the second is that climate
suitability actually should be climate
change I suppose should shift but not
necessarily increase the distribution of
infectious disease and that's fairly
contrary to what tends to be reported in
the literature in addition even though
climate becomes more suitable for
infectious diseases in cases where it
does become more suitable we don't
necessarily expect that parasites will
respond because there are other
important factors like economics that
may overshadow those climate effects we
hypothesis that biodiversity loss mostly
reduces parasites this is exactly the
opposite of what you'll find in most of
the conservation biology literature and
then finally invasive species both bring
and escape parasites and both of those
phenomenon are problematic in terms of
conservation biology thank you very much